let's kick haris out for a sec no leave
him in hello good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever the hell you are
in the world and welcome to CRA your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel live with
wine I haven't got a drink I've not got
a drink this time and you've got
two I do I'm gonna be needing a way
halfway
through I did a video yesterday with mac
and um and I was I nearly popped I was I
nearly had an accident if ever anybody
ever like Clips a bunch of videos of me
going
at the end of
[Music]
L end ah Dave is in the house uh Steve
is in the house that that was from me uh
and Sarah hi guys how are we all doing
right we alive it's a bit of a hangout
video it's a bit of a whatever the hell
you want video we are early for Harris
and then he's not
here he's making ribs for Jenny styven
yeah he met her yesterday and now all of
a sudden is making her
food she's Jenny styen has adopted
Harris yeah um I've already I messaged
her a little while ago saying um I hear
our young American pounced on you
pounced on you yesterday or did you
pounce on him and she's literally just
messaged me back I was so happy to see
him I can't wait to meet Jen she's over
here she's in the UK next year we have
to try and do something um is she coming
to Bas though no she is over here for
something I forget what it was um but
she's already said she's going to be up
this way so I said right beer Ken how
you doing sir um and and Laura's in as
well they're Usual Suspects right so um
we could talk about whatever we want
anybody wants to get in the comments and
tell us what you want to talk about but
I do want to talk about Doctor
Who because we've had two episodes
dropped now with David Tenant and oh
sorry friends David Tenant and um and
the doct donor and you um hate it and I
love it which is weird so I know say the
wrong I don't hate the episodes but I
didn't love them first of all just just
right I I loved the second episode I
liked the
first okay why didn't you love the first
episode because nothing
happened that's fair it it wasn't it was
a very good episode because we had David
tanon and Don Global back yeah and they
they wrapped up the whole Dr
Donna um meta crisis thing and saved
Donna great
but the whole Meep storyline was fine
but it was more like a filler episode
kind of thing the
MEEP the Meep yeah not he MEEP the Meep
yeah the Meep yeah the doctor yeah
exactly I I I just felt and I talked
about this yesterday so I'm not going to
go on and on and on about it but there
was um a transgender character and she
was amazing I think she's she's a she's
just a lovely young lady and I think
she's a really I've seen her in a couple
of interviews um she's had some crap in
her life of people shouting things at
her um I actually thought the way the
nanny the Nan um Donna Noble's mom was
written saying so like oh am I to say
she's pretty I don't really know what to
say I actually thought that was a lovely
put because my generation in particular
and older oh my nan has no freaking clue
about she doesn't know she doesn't want
to offend anyone she just doesn't
understand it um and I and I'm sort of
in the same boat sort of thing I don't I
just don't know what to say I don't know
what to um thing uh I have absolutely I
don't do I do not give a crap if you
want to shave your head and call
yourself Susan tomorrow I don't really
care I just would not quite know how to
you've already done it uh I wouldn't
quite know how to sort of like apprach
it and you'd have to help me through and
occasionally I might call you he and I
would ask you not to punch me in the
face I'm just like I'm so sorry I made a
mistake please don't kill me um I did
have a lady uh who was transgender who
had a go at me once because I used the
word they talking about um the gay
community and she exploded who's they
what's they and exploded at me and I
goes it's a connective it's a word that
means a group of people I don't know why
you're angry at me and I just I didn't
understand it and I just
thought but is difficult I wasn't trying
to be my latest video I made that point
that I tried to use the appropriate
language but sometimes it is difficult
because it's not a world I'm in I didn't
say that exactly but that's the general
point it's it's difficult but you try as
long as you try I think I'm I don't even
I don't even try particular I do try in
the sense of I don't but I I'm on the
sense of I don't want to offend anyone
any any culture race religion uh ethnic
you I I I don't really want to offend
anyone I would quite happily go through
my life and not offend anyone if you
don't do anything personal to me I if
you do personal to me I will attack
anything about you I will call you uh
you're too tall bald beaded and I will I
will I will attack anything because if
you personally attack me or actually
it's not even personally attack me if
you personally attack someone I
love I I I'm not a pleasant person if
you if you go after somebody I love um
to be honest you could do pretty much
whatever you want to me and I just like
give a crap um but um I'm gonna give you
a nugie when I meet you yeah and and I'd
have to admit I did I
was I was very offensive towards um he
was a gay fell and I did I mean if out
of context I was it sounded like a hate
crime um but he had just been really
[__] to my girlfriend at the time and
I just attacked anything that I thought
would upset him I didn't care that I
don't care he's gay toss but um I I just
went at him because he'd gone at my
girlfriend so I just I just attacked him
and anything I could throw out and um
and that's not my one of my proudest
moments I will admit but he'd he
offended me so um but anyway Doctor Who
I just thought they Bang the Drum a bit
too many times about the whole the
doctor who can be a man or a woman or
the whole transgender thing it's just it
it wasn't that it wasn't that they made
the point it was they made the point
about six times and I'm like by the end
of it I'm was like yeah okay the whole
um Donna and Rose and that they were
able to share it and then they basically
made that big thing of the doctor isn't
a man a woman or a them it's more than
that I'm like you've already made this
point a few times um admit when when
they when they did that line um when uh
Donna goes binary binary and then it
cuts to row saying non-binary I did
winse a little bit Yeah because I I felt
like it was a little
bit like obviously I've got no problem
with
it but I didn't think it fitted as well
as it could they could have done better
for me if that was the only if they have
built up to that and that was the big
thing I'd have been okay with that
individually I have absolutely no
problem with any
the bit with a meep when you know says
and doctor says he and then Rose jumps
on him say no that's the wrong pronoun
you need to check what pronoun he wants
to go by and I'm like oh god um and I'm
just like okay that's fine I have no
problem with individually with any of
those points when they're making a point
I just had a problem when it got to the
end of the episode and it was like eight
or n you know it it was just like again
they're making the point again come on
um it's it's that was my only issue um
and and they've made him gay now so and
again don't give a crap made gay little
bit no I just thought was because he
because he he said Isaac Newton was an
attractive
fell um I just always argue to anybody
that says like Doctor Who's a man I'm
like is he he's an alien we don't know
what he
is you're putting our tury rules onto a
his his gender is the most fluid thing
in the in the universe
by by extension so what his sexuality
because we don't actually know what his
sexuality is I mean we know he's he's
had he must have had a mate at one point
because he had Susan as his
granddaughter and then he was with River
but River being a Time Lord could
effectively become a man at some point
and he became a woman so like what is
sexuality for a Time Lord like it's
irrelevant they're probably close to
pansexuals where they where they like
someone for the personality rather than
the gender or the sex um is it's a
question is Russell T Davis though
trying to piss people off pardon my
French with the the people that are
annoyed about the woke thing and like
there are there are
people um in the woke that that shout
woke at things a lot that are racist sex
they're bigots and they use the whole
woke argument to basically legitimize
their um own bigot Behavior there are
people out woke that genuinely are just
sick to death of being preached at and
they're not you know they're not
particularly they they might they might
be a little bit racist but they're not
like they're not racist they're not
sexist they're
just they're just sick of being preached
out like for me I don't consider myself
I I consider myself quite liberal I hate
the word woke I hate it I would say a
million times I'll keep banging that
drum I hate this word I hate this word
um but I didn't like the do Tre and what
I didn't like was the that Sir Isaac
Newton is all of a sudden an Asian
fellow why did they do that I think
there's a big bear with a woke t-shirt
on and Russell T Davis is poking it come
on come on I I I I think you might be
right because
he he doesn't care what people
think he has a story to tell and he's
going to tell that
story I do think there is you've got
there is some element of Truth in that
where he'll basically put things in to
annoy people because he knows people
will talk about it and
therefore make the show more popular it
it can backfire though which we have
seen it can backfire rings of power it
backfired massively yeah it can backfire
but I I don't know if it's necessarily a
conscious thing that he's doing or if
it's just kind of just like I'm going to
do it anyway I'm just going to do this
blah blah blah blah if if anyone talks
about it that's free publicity kind of
thing and it might not be like a
conscious let's piss people off kind of
thing but there might be an element of
truth to it somewhere I think a lot of
Executives because I mean a lot of
people that that again are very angry
about recently about work thing um when
they gender swap I want to talk about
gender swapping in a minute because I
don't think this as big of problem as
people make out but um they gender swap
or they R swap some I think sometimes
their executives are doing it because
they think no
um it'll get
clicks we're going to we're going to
gender swap race Swap this character
that's beloved and and people will and
it'll get loads and loads of clicks I
think the whole she trying to do that
and it backfired on them as well the
reason in that
episode they must people talk about like
diversity quota kind of thing thing all
the time and I think that that that is
true there probably is some sort of like
diversity quot that they have to meet
the Productions that they make BBC
probably if if you think about that
episode without Isaac Newton the entire
cast was David Tenant and Katherine Tate
yeah so the only other character would
have had to have been if if they had
meeting these quoters would have had to
have been person of
color possibly yeah because it's
literally the only other actor in the
entire episode isn't it yeah
but and I think that might be the reason
why they put it
in um because you could take that out
and it does it changes the it doesn't
change the episode at all the only thing
it changed in the episode was their
definition of or the their of gravity
gravity J gravity joke yeah but you
didn't that didn't have to be there it
it really didn't have to be there but no
I see I don't maybe there's something
that says you have to have more than
three people in an
episode there has to be diversity thing
and the BBC has rules like that to be
fair the BBC is so because it's part
funded by the government as well the
government sort of insists they do
certain things which is just ridiculous
and because we help pay we well we pay
for it so the Govern some smart ass in a
group somewhere I'll go yeah make sure
you got at least 20% Asian in in each
show or something that then it probably
happens or minority I should say um oh I
didn't have an issue with it because
Harris is with us just have an issue
with Isaac being what
an I did look at him I go I'm sure he's
meant to be white but
honestly no difference haris let me get
the camera let me get the lights on is
it missl toe do we need to kiss there
going to be a problem because ah okay oh
my nice ribs for Jenny right here nice
she wanted a honey glaze so she gets a
nice honey glaze on top of
it I
want all right I'll be right back I'm g
go toss in the oven real fast okay sir
wow oh man I'm so hungry um what we say
uh yeah I I don't know about the BBC
with that um like you said then I'm like
that just that just like went what as
soon as they did that I was just like as
soon as the Apple fell I was like oh God
that's suris I don't have any problem
with race swapping a character I I
really don't um if if they should do
they should do the best actors for a
role and if that's a black guy or a
white guy or a purple guy I don't really
care or girl could be a girl um but when
it's a historical
character I mean we've been doing this
to Jesus for 2,000 years we making him a
White English guy with a beard um Jesus
um when I'm pretty sure he'd have a time
at very least being being brought up in
the Middle East
um one of the videos I watched from
podcast of the Lotus Eaters which if any
of you watched that I I urge you not to
because they're they were poison your
mind he made the
point of um bill being a black
lesbian um and then
mentioned some some episode where they
they historic the the the Victorian
people were all black people for
whatever reason and the doctor then goes
yeah but Jesus was
black and and then and then this guy on
the on the Lotus podcast goes no he
wasn't that's factually in acccurate and
I'm like no it's not he lived in a
[__]
desert' um the Middle Eastern is they're
not they're not black are they they're
not um they're not white are they
they're not white not not pale as me let
no he's not he's not a pale blue color
like me either um but but yeah it's
exactly it's point but I would just say
that you know um yeah we need space
Jesus
um I I just think that
like I understand having diversity
because any production should reflect
Society right so um there should be a
mix of of of what that Society is and if
you've just got a a black or a gay or or
whatever they as long as it roughly
reflect Society I'm I'm all for it no
problem at all the rings of power thing
because it had a a black elf I
completely understand where people were
annoyed coming from because if saying
all the elves are supposed to be Nordic
supposed to be white blond haired and
I'm like yeah but Jr Tolen um his whole
the whole thing of The Lord of the Rings
was about um uh that racism is stupid
basically it's about bringing lots of
different races together to solve a
problem he was talking it was following
World War I I think and you know like
coming together to fight evil I actually
think if Jr tolken was around today the
elves would have been mixed race they
just would have been so I have no
problem with that because I could I
could see where it would I I could see
what they were trying to
do um and like Lenny Henry's character
we know they're darker skinned because
Jr Tolen wrote that they're darker
skinned than the other things so
um so I have no problem with that but
when it's an historical
figure you shouldn't do that and and you
can have you can have something from
Victoria England and have black people
in it and actually it's historically
accurate and you can thank the Romans
for it
because people were moved all over from
North Africa into Europe and stuff
because they were slaves and some stayed
it is it is not it is not accurate to
say there were no black people in
Britain and particularly in London um in
say the you know the 15th 16th century
because they
were um it was rare but they were um so
if you're gonna if you're going to start
druming the historically accurate drum
you better know your
history you know what I mean you better
know that actually what you're saying is
accurate because that that it isn't
accurate to say there were no black
people in Britain um 500 years ago
because they were um it was just rare I
don't think it should be an in in
relation to Doctor Who this isn't an
issue
because it isn't our
universe it's a universe very much like
ours with
historical events that happened very
much like
ours but we there's never been a d
invasion of London there's never been a
Cyberman invasion of
London there was I saw it on the T no
and and like basically it's it's like
looking at a universe that's like ours
so having slight things different like
Isaac Newton slightly Indian it doesn't
it doesn't change anything it's still
Isaac Newton that guy is still playing
the Isaac Newton from our universe in
that Universe like it doesn't make a
difference like the color of your skin
makes no
difference I don't quite agree with you
but I'm not going to lose sleep over it
I'm not I didn't I didn't pick up my
phone and immediately go on Twitter I
just sort of went oh Russell T this is
gonna get
letters as far as I went umly though
that is the only criticism I've seen
from that
episode yeah the I actually genuinely
didn't particularly like the episode I
thought it was a bit boring and you
saying about how nothing happened in the
first I didn't think
particularly it was a bit
slow um it went on a bit um I enjoyed it
it was an hour it was an hour and five
minutes it was the longest episode um
one of the longest episodes today for
sure I am yeah David how big is Harris's
house he's only walked to the OV
M he's falling in we've we've actually
got a suspicion that Harris's parents
are quite wealthy look after
him um yeah from from an episode point
of view I thought it was all right that
whole thing with the um Asian thing I
just want the went why did he do that as
much as anything
else gender swapping characters though
right so I asked on on Community page
about a week and a half ago or something
can you can you give me 10 examples of
when they've gender swapped a character
right and we got and we got few we got
we got load because I'm like I don't
think it happens as much as people think
um you know um somebody will throw a
comment on saying you know oh we'll have
a um a female whatever character next
and it'll be black gay and like okay I'm
not sure but how how after how often
does it actually
happen um and I think the only examples
I can think of is Doctor Who but it
makes sense in in relation to that
character and then there was
Ghostbusters but it wasn't really gender
swapping that was characters completely
different characters they were different
characters yeah um it's Happ Battlestar
Galactic had two and Boomer and um
uh starb were both were both gened there
was a
series KY zakov worked 100% worked both
characters 100% um and I saw the writers
um and I've said this before but the
writers basically said with starbook
um this is a boring character we need to
do something different that character as
a woman all of a sudden is
interesting um as as a bloke is just
another generic it's just we it's done
it and and no one's going to be better
than dirke Benedict anyway so let's do
something different so that there was no
agenda to that it was it was a story
agenda it was a this this makes it
interesting
um Dave B Mario arti now that was really
clever so in
elementary they had I've checked this
I've actually spoken to somebody about
this and he said yeah you're right um I
suspected so it's Sherlock Holmes story
right and they had Joan Watson and it
was um Lucy Lou this is this is my
Maru oh yes he is the best Mar um and I
always said I've always wondered if they
just had they had Lucy L cont to do a
series and they were just like we need
to to we need it for something okay we
got the sherock Hol series coming
that'll do and um I spoke to and they're
like yeah that's basically that was his
basic understanding of what happened
they just needed somebody they weren't
they weren't particularly bothered about
it being a female they just needed to
give Lucy Lou a show because she was
contracted to do something um so that
that was the was but then they did it
with maratti as well but I actually
thought it was really really clever
because the Sherlock Holmes character
has got um the love interest of Sherlock
Holmes uh I called the I forgot the
character's name the lady but he called
the lady sometimes um but then what they
did they switched it and made in her
into Mar arti as well and I was like
well of course because it's his arch
rival and then it's somebody that equals
his intelligence and that's why he loved
it so you know he loved it so I always
thought that was brilliant way they did
that I always wish they've done it a bit
more because then we never then really
saw her again um but again it was do
really well
um marveled it quite a lot to be fair
their gender swap characters quite a
lot um but they've in their comic books
though they've they just make female
versions of the most popular characters
so you've got spider Gwen you've got um
shehulk you've got a lot of the time the
the female four I don't know what her
name is but female four and they've done
female Superman female Supergirl they've
done they are they are their own
characters though it's not really a
gender they sometimes do it like Side
characters like in
um uh what was it called Jessica Jones
the the lawyer in it is supposed to be a
bloke and it's a woman um and I always
think that was because they had um oh
God what's her name from The Matrix Car
Mar yeah um that I always think they
just had they were just like ah she's
willing to do something what what can we
do ah she'll be Aces this let's just do
that it's supposed to be a bloke that's
fine caran Moss is doing it and nobody
cared I didn't even know but because
it's backup characters on didn't know so
um I think when when they do it to back
characters I think it matters
particularly um but main characters I
generally I can't think of
any that mattered or that didn't work
that weren't better in Marvel in
anything where
they the task master the only one the
only one I can think of um but that was
that didn't matter that it was a woman
it was just
crap you want about the the the the game
show Taskmaster or is it like a Black
Widow Black Widow the the villain in
Black Widow is Task Master um not the
Greg Davis show no not the Greg Davis
show you you wouldn't know about that
Young Harris um but um I think people
are more annoyed about that because the
Taskmaster was a brilliant character and
they just underused it massively it just
wasn't very good didn't matter that it
was a woman no the actors was just fine
they just didn't do the character
right I think that's the problem with
jod Whitaker's
doctor she's a fantastic actress she's a
fantastic actress
but she was [__] as as a doctor but I
don't think it's her fault it was bad
right because if she if she was given
proper like character development and
actual good story
lines she would have been really good I
mean saying that she was really good in
flux I really enjoyed flux and I really
enjoyed power of the doctor
yeah but everything
else it's forgettable that's the only
word I can describe I think Peter
Capaldi is a brilliant actor I
absolutely adored him in that thing he
did before in BBC where he swore
constantly that political show he did of
it um yeah he was amazing in that so
when he was done as the doctor I was
like yes that is an actor I I I love
that guy it was crap I stopped watching
it I watched maybe three episodes P Kali
and I stopped watching it I was like
this is rubbish um had character
development
well again they started yeah was wiped
his memory or something had they he
didn't know who he was or something um
he know who he was he just didn't know
why he had that
face yeah I know there was some like
mental it almost like he'd done too many
times had he he merged too many sorry um
changed too many times and he was like
it broke his brain or something um well
so he wanted to know why he he got that
face cu the last time he saw it was in
the fires of pompe where saved where
Donna basically said to him you could
say you can save someone I think it was
Donna it might have been Martha I think
it was done anyway so you you can save
someone so this once he saved someone
and it happened to be that guy played by
Peter
Capaldi and then wondered why he was
getting that face back and it's
basically be so he as the doctor would
learn again that it's okay to save
someone every now and and then David be
just said there though that how many
times has a man taken over a woman's
role
it happens but how many times is a woman
taken over a man's role people always
point to um sigor Weaver and Aliens
saying that look that's a strong female
character it was written as a
man it was supposed to be a man um and
uh the director basically went this
would work better as a woman um and and
so they did it it worked and in the
first and they still patronized the crap
out of her it's you know they still made
the jokes like you know about being a
woman and that it wouldn't have done
they wouldn't have done that the other
way it's still quite
patronizing if I was um if if I'm a
bloke and I'm in the in that movie in
Aliens particularly and Michael
um oh BN comes up to me and starts
showing me how to use the rifle I'm
shooting that man in the foot I was like
don't patronize me little [__] I didn't
ask I didn't ask you to show me how this
works but he did because and and they
made a point to that then she just
goes do it and sort and um but it was
still quite patronized bit weird but um
I didn't need to say a guy in a skimpy
dress
anyway don't we don't need that Jims
just made a very good point the jender
swap worked perfectly for the master
Missy it did that was fantastic Missy
was great Michelle Gomez is
like I
AB scary
but funny as fees isn't she she's Marv
um but but yeah
um I like that as well because they
built it up didn't they we didn't know
who this character was and she was
insane and then went it's the master oh
[__] that's that's so good it was done
really really well well didn't very well
go calling myself the master now could I
the
mistress so what do you think about this
storyline because you you probably know
better than me because I've not watched
do who for years I've watched these two
episodes and that's it um this whole
story L that he's not G Fran the doctor
yeah so yeah Chris tribel decided
to um everyone hates this absolutely
everyone hates this Doctor Who fans woke
people everyone hates this because it's
[__] right
so rewind back to the 2005 Revival he
was the last of the time laws because of
the time War they managed to save galif
Fray yeah and then it disappeared again
they saved it one more time and then
this all happened over the span of like
10 years Chris chel comes along and has
the master offscreen destroy Gala Fray
completely because he didn't like the
secret he that they kept about the
doctor which is essentially that the
doctor fell through a rift in the
universe and then the time Lords
experimented on the doctor and that's
how they got their regenerative powers
so all of Time Lord Society is based on
the doctor which makes makes him slash
her the most important character in that
Universe when the beauty of the show was
never that the doctor is the most
important person in the University was
just a just a time lord and Outcast
someone who ran away and just did his
best he wasn't this superpowered like
Godlike being that created the time
Lords right and then they're following
up that they're trying to fix it again
now aren't they so they're trying to
main no no he's he's sticking with it
he's sticking with it he said he's gonna
um
um not on it uh I don't know what I
don't know what the the word is well
let's see if they can make something
good out of it anyway it I guess it
happened essentially okay have you seen
Doctor Who Young Harris or are you too
busy at La comic no new La ComiCon isn't
La ComiCon but I have not seen any
Doctor Who ever whatsoever
actually don't bother you um
oops well anyway so we've covered that
um do we want to talk about when they
talk swap well the swap race and things
I think we've covered it we we don't we
we don't mind it but for me anyway I
don't mind it um I don't care either way
a lot of the time I just as long as it
doesn't become go past the story and
know I always use the Ghostbusters with
boobs example I did not care that they
were they were doing Ghostbusters with
women the problem was they cared that
they were doing Ghostbusters with women
and they told us repeatedly through the
film The we're women yes move on um and
it became the the I think they saw the
news reports about how you can't be
women and they just went [__] you well
we'll write an entire movie about it
then and it's boring and it's not very
good if that was a good film though
nobody would have mentioned it not
that's a problem bad writing is
generally what we
yeah
but anyway it's a difficult it's it is
it is a
difficult story it is a difficult thing
and I can understand where people
sometimes think it but at the same time
this is all
fiction and we have to draw a line in it
somewhere like look look okay like me
yesterday with Isaac Newton is an Asian
fell I'm not writing to my mp over it
all I did was I sit there and
went why did you do that and that's as
that's as much as really us that's about
as upset as you to get about these
things um because it is fiction it's not
real so anyway
so Harris yes you're to
ComicCon yes with my negative sleep of
ComicCon I I sat down and I was like oh
it looks like I haven't slept this
weekend great but I have not it's been a
good weekend it's it's been lot of fun
it's I'm it's it's kind of back to what
it was pre pandemic at this point which
is very nice very very nice it's La
ComiCon you jumped on Jenny styen or
Jenny styen jumped on you we're not sure
which way that went and when did when
did who are you it's it's evil Matt with
his glasses is this Mir or ver Matt
what's going on it's super thing is
that um but anyway anything interesting
happened any news you want to
or anything or not really um I don't
know if it was any ComiCon related thing
or anything but yesterday there were
hell of a lot of trailers that announced
and a little meme about that
but I don't think there's anything
really new I did cosplay for the very
first time yesterday one of my uh
friends is like a big cosplayer on Tik
Tok and stuff and I don't have a Tik Tok
even so I don't do anything like that
you know um but he had extra costumes So
I dressed up as Wolverine and uh my
buddy that's that's staying with me uh
just dressed up as Ant-Man because we we
got extra costumes from him
and I haven't taken that many pictures
besides like vacations with my mom it's
the most pictur I've ever taken in my
life which was a hell of a lot of fun
but people do that for a living that's a
lot that's a
lot yeah yeah yeah nothing like exciting
I guess I wish there was something
exciting but I'm bringing Jenny rib you
got pictures of you in this Wolverine
costume I need see yeah actually
probably onto the Facebook group mate
that's a good idea I got to get them off
of other people's phones I didn't take a
single picture while I was there I'm
kind of angry at
myself that means you enjoyed yourself
exactly there's kind of me sitting there
in a wolverine suit for a
second there Captain America yeah
there's there's C that's my budy that
gave us the costumes for the day yeah
cool you look so
depressed I was I was in the middle of a
a drink I was I was I was posing for the
picture we were getting uh
characterized it was funny yeah but I
mean Logan isn't exactly a laugh a
minute is he he's quite a grumpy
character so well done getting in
character yeah I'm try I'm
trying I feel like Logan should swear
way more than he does yeah well I got
that he he should be like um butcher
from the
boys
am through he would swear more as much
if not more than butcher from the
B yeah and he wouldn't give a crap
either so
no um drink anybody it' be
dangerous I just saw somebody Jordin
ators asked if there's any um Stargate
rumors nothing I haven't heard anything
this week I haven't heard anything since
um I heard a rumor be next year that I
heard heard a rumor that when new
Stargate does come out yeah it's going
to be round and there going to be nine
Chevrons on
it okay and some of them will light
up okay I don't rumor or what we've seen
before no no no no that's completely new
yeah we've never had that before okay it
was more egg shaped yeah now we're now
we're going uh yeah it should be an
octagon there we go okay here's another
rumor it's going to be triangle and
instead of Chevrons it's going to be
Donuts I like donuts it could be
hexagons and it's actually proving that
we're in a matrix and everything is
pixelated yeah and in the comments guys
be nice to each other I'm seeing there a
little bit of an argument going on but
be nice to each other we we we respect
each other's opinions even if we're not
Mar um just be nice um and John Joe my
cousin's name is John
Joe no point just he is John or Joe no
his name is jono you can't have both you
can be one or the other you're John
or his name is
j um and he's British which is so weird
it's so fun to say
Jano it does it does sound Japanese
doesn't
it I think sounds like like Southern
States of America you expect like
yeah I swear I go over to Louisiana and
meet a j day of the week I'm so sorry
we're insulting you here but you it does
sound like you're married to your cousin
it just I'm so
sorry um and that's my that's my cousin
I'm insulting him not you um oh that's a
subscri have you seen that that's that
um that bit by Tom seura and he's like
he goes to a hotel and he goes are you
are you Japanese and he goes no and the
guy they have friend goes Saga he goes
it's just sigura you're making it
Japanese I could do the same thing with
Smith Smith
SM any I just thought that when I said
it sounded
Japanese cracks me
up I you know talk about being um a bit
bit bit racist I said that I'm gonna go
to the [__] to go get a Chinese and my
mate had to point out and I was like I'm
not allowed to say that
no why you're not allowed to say the the
word for for for Corner Shop either
that's not allowed I said that
racist know I don't mean it I didn't
realize that you know as me and our
winkies we have the you know the the the
the little Hall where the we what what's
that called sorry is is is yeah is a
Japanese person's eye which is racist
yes I
I think that that I think that word
transcends the the racist meaning
because now it just means dick hole it
doesn't meanes person's eye it doesn't
is that the same in the states would you
call it a
japy no never heard that no like japy
like a like a yeah
like
POC
oh it no not familiar I'm with you now
though
you know I've never I never got but then
I did say that that what you were on
about the corner shop Mt and I just said
it because then as soon as I said I was
like I've not said that in years that is
so it was such a big thing in the 90s
when I was growing up everyone said it
and I had I had a friend from um
Pakistan he was like one of my best
mates and he was like I hate people that
[__] say that and that got me
thinking and I'm like why that's just
what everyone calls it like yeah but oh
no he wasn't from Pakistan sorry he was
[Music]
um oh where was he from India I can't I
actually can't remember he wasn't from
Pakistan anyway and people people would
call it the insert P abbreviation for
Pakistani yeah
shop and that's why he hated it because
it's just a Capt all for any brown
person who owns a corner shop it got it
got to the point where it was just it's
not even just that it was just you know
what sort of shop you're on about so
it's like um like a deli or something
like that Harris over there they sell
magazine sweets cigarettes thing and and
then normally so we used to call it the
corner shop but then we started calling
it the pan shop because it was always
run by Indians and stuff in this country
and it's just it's just a thing um but I
I called it that and but as a kid I had
no racial thing that's just what
everyone called it and then when it came
out of my mouth as an ad by mistake
because I was trying to say we that's
the sort of shop we need I wasn't saying
got K runs it could
be Umpa lumper for like care um but um
and I and I'm just like oh sh but I was
really I was like oh God that's not
coming out my face anges but then I
suddenly started saying and then yeah I
S like I'm going to the [__] over the
road and my mate was just like you can't
[__] say that I've no one Ur you and
I was like I was just the Chinese and
and but then it so dawned on me like oh
yeah
that'sit and but it's my point is anyway
that we have these things from when
we're younger from remember I grew up in
the 80s remember so people were a bit
more you know leftwing anyway um and but
some of these
things that doesn't make you racist at
all stupid it makes you no it
just it just means in your brain
somewhere is the remnant of the the
generation before us who was racist and
made that word and it's just follow me
through and it's not necessarily
ignorant as you said as a child you said
it and it wasn't there was no ra behind
it yeah un I think I didn't even realize
it meant like a Japanese eye I just I
genuinely believed it was just called a
chy i because I'd never thought about it
and that's the problem I'd never thought
about it and then one day I just started
thinking oh and it just dawned on me but
I I'm I can be a bit stupid sometimes my
my dad my mom and dad call each other
Rick um because rickon Rick probably
shouldn't say that I know everyone knows
my name anyway Rick um but my dad you
literally have your name on Facebook
with about 3,000 people I
know so my little brother calls my dad
Baldrick like Baldrick from um Ada yeah
never never occurred to me what he was
on about and for years and and then one
day it sort of went and I mean years I
went because he's bald and a Col for a
RI and my brother's like why did you
think because I don't know I just never
thought about it it never i' never you
just did it and I never occurred to me
to think so yeah that's the thing I
think yeah now we need to over I think
the we need to think everything it's
accidentally racist
before in in my in my not last job the
job before I had a mate right from
Zimbabwe really really black right yeah
I don't I don't know if that's
inappropriate to say but like when I
when when I you know how you got
different shades like he was black he
was black yeah yeah yeah he wouldn't
mind me saying that because like it's
still my M but anyway I was accidentally
racist because because he was following
me around and I went I'm not going to
say his name but I was like insert name
Go away You're My
Shadow and then I didn't understand what
I had said and then they were like you
can't say that I like why not he's
following me
around they like but Shadows are black
I'm
like
um I I had a lad who called and a um a
black F monkey boy um and we were like M
you can't say that and he was just like
what he's on his third banana and we
were like oh and go this guy um he had a
potassium issue so he was basically told
he had to eat like four or five Bananas
a Day to try and get his potassium
levels up so he's just eating loads and
loads of Banas so he called him monkey
boy and we were like can't say that shut
up no look look he's eating another
freaking banana never even occurred to
him that there's any racial thing he
just saw a guy eating bananas and went
you boy and and and my mate laughed his
ass off of that he thought it was so
funny and because but then he did s
after he s you can't call me that though
M very funny but you can't call me that
um people will shout at um but yeah I I
think the most the people that worry
most about racism though are white
middle-aged
women and I think uh I think they worry
about more about racism than anyone else
um I I got um it's the same with like
homophobia and and my mate um who is's
he's he's been gay he's been gay his
whole life weirdly he didn't just switch
one day even though he did get laid a
lot when he was younger with with ladies
he and but then he he came out um but he
just said a lot I get a lot he was gay
he took them shopping afterwards well
yeah there you
go because he tricked them um say that
I'm by yeah but um he was talk about um
I get I get a lot of abuse from
middle-aged men I get a lot of that that
that's who tends to shout at me but the
people that stress about it the most are
middleaged women they really worry no
you can't see this you can't see that
and they and and because uh one of my
pals called him a very
unpleasant
uh no I'm not saying it so a very
unpleasant way of describing a gab and
my mate thought my gay M he thought that
was a fun is it is it the word that is
also a food yeah um so um and so he
called him that um but we were in a pub
and he said it really loudly you
effing um and and
some and and my mate was like my my my
homosexual friend was like excuse me
love the only person here that can get
offended at that is me you do not get
offended on my behalf thank you very
much I think that's more of a derogatory
term in America like I don't really hear
it that much in the
UK like it's more like in the UK it's oh
you puff BTY boy like I've been called a
puff my entire life it's like yeah and
what everything isatori in America yeah
puff is Puff is literally the piece of
furniture that sits in the middle of the
room that you put your feet on yeah that
is a puff not [__] someone who likes
men
yeah um Jay needs to stop being such a
bundle of
sticks
cigarettes what what you call
cigarettes yeah [__] uh okay Bund sticks
yeah of
sticks oh God that's like if someone
needs to edit this and just have like a
sound drop of a penny
dropping um we don't call them sticks
so okay we call them [__] cigarettes uh
cancer sticks
um
[Music]
yeah popc how many calories that is
that's 500 calories in bananas
alone a mad
man um I think he's I think he was um
very irregular because of it he didn't
um the doctor told him he was actually
supposed to take potassium um pills I
think and he just went lo lo bananas but
bananas buying you up quite badly so it
didn't go very well but anyway um so
eggs weirdly sorry so did eggs weirdly
yeah I thought you said something
totally
different what what did you think I said
I'll tell you after I'm not gonna say
it I've got a mate who's still I've got
a mate who's still to this day is called
umper um because he was told um yeah
he's an ump umper he was he drank so
much orange juice it genuinely turned
his skin a slightly orange color um he
um he'd been told like that he he needs
to drink more orange by the doctor so he
just went upset and that's all he drank
for like six months he just drank loads
which it was ridiculous and um didn't
tell anybody else what he's doing so but
all of a sudden he's went my my skin
orange and it literally it it will turn
your skin a slightly orange color so
that happens to some bloo at carrots
like nonstop yeah Dr carrots it was
carrots he was eating he was eating car
sorry it's cartine isn't it that's right
it carrots um this was 25 years ago so I
think but 25 years later we still call
him
umper we I we' never call him by his
name it's always
Donald just change it up and he W it
still mean the same thing but he won't
know well we called him bugs for a while
and then um it changed to umper um and
then you know when he's Ang we know
we're angry at him because you call him
umper lumper if somebody's angry at him
like uses full
name when your mom out she uses your
full name you know you're in trouble so
don't to piss out him for
that I've got a mate who whose name is
um he's the same as me he's five foot
seven but he's the hairiest man alive
when he shaves he has to shave from
there right it's ridiculous um his beard
starts just under his eye sockets mine
doesn't go any higher than like here
yeah well he's the hairest man Al life
he he grew out his ear hair and um
started spiking it with hair gel just
this
um man with
fire call him Ewok and I still get Ewok
I get called Ewok quite a lot um uh and
he he actually calls me Ewok to be fair
you should be thring yeah I should be
shouldn't i e well no when I've got my
goatey on a Feeling an evil
Ewok um but he had this girlfriend years
ago and um um she um had her boobs done
so she got her um a topless photo of
herself putting one of those Lad Mags
that we used to have like 20 years ago
um but she lied about her AG y Sor yeah
FHM yeah nuts smoke but she lied about
her age and said she was 19 she was like
28 or something she said she was 19 so
um we all got old to this and we were
like his the ex by this point because
your ex has got pretty nice nice boobies
uh and then somebody's went 19 you've
got a seven-year-old daughter with this
girl so um so we started calling him
peock pile leok Oh
god well we pinned him down one day and
shaved pwac into this back of his
head just because he he messed something
up so we we abused him but um yeah and
he still gets called pewo this day it's
been 20
years um I rectum I get called rectum a
lot because I thought you said erectum I
was like what I'm that's that's a whole
puzzle piece to unload there when I was
16 I worked at McDonald's and my manager
just appeared going
rectum and we were like going what the
hell is wrong with Paulie and he goes
wreck and he walks right up to me
wrecked him I was like dude what's wrong
because when you put your name into a
spell checker it comes out
rectum
he was so happy about it I come in the
next day my name badge and my my
clocking card has changed to
rectum um that was 30 years ago nearly
um like like 28 years ago and um my mate
my one mate in particular has never
called me by my real name since not
once I am recked him that's
it you're saying we need to make you a a
Sid Jersey that says rectum on the back
instead of your actual name and then put
a Stargate in the middle of the back
right under it oh yes well if I get a
tattoo done for when we hit 50k or if we
have hit 50k it might have to be
rect it's such an unfortunate nickname
to have and but now I'm 45 years old I
don't care but at the time I hated it
really hatte I think that's why you
stuck with it I really hated it
um great science fiction related quite a
unique surname I've never met a rickon
before there aren't any my my actual
surname I've never met another one of
them
either well it makes it really nice me
to when I'm creating like email
addresses and things I don't have to put
my I could just use my real name and but
basically it comes down to my name was
spell wrong on a census about a 100
years ago so we're literally the only
ones that's was it meant to be well it
was ricken with a n which there is
another family that's so there are some
rxs around here
but basically it comes from that we
couldn't spell our name so you know you
get the X for what they used to do in
the census you just put an X and that's
where it's come from um but my family
were farmers and there's a thing when
you um stack hay and like you know they
do it like that sort of thing in a big
like like looks like a teepe that's to
caller Ricks so that's where it comes
from my my family were farmers and so
that's where that's where it comes from
you specialize in in stacking hay we
love to Hay we love stacking hay mate
all year round it's all we did we
stacked hey we like should we grow some
Morey somebody's got to do it hey hey
hey um we're like should we should we
stack some more hay oh like I'm gonna
grow some hay why just stack it might
been barley might when stack barley but
anyway I'm not F so okay your family
started hay stacking competitions is
what I'm saying yeah yeah y'all started
the needle and the hay stack um saying
just go with it you got it needle in a
massive freaking pile of needles that's
my prefer I prefer that say it's like
find a needle in a massive freaking pile
of needles um but but yeah be terrible
in like a hundred years if the instead
of the N to the m your unfortunate
nickname turned rum into rectum and then
it turned into rectum but you do it now
it doesn't come out like that so it's
just like an old like it like Microsoft
three did it um it's not we didn't grow
potatoes apparently we grew
hey it doesn't yeah you're right I get
Dixon or
fixing thick skin what fixing oh okay
see it doesn't do it anymore but it used
to anyway but like I said that made that
guy the most happy he'd ever
been and and think this is when the
store is open there's a bunch of
customers there going why is that guy
screaming wck him at that little
kid I was only 16 I used to always love
giving people nicknames there was a girl
I used to work with and her name was
Steph I I called her
Gwen right Gwen
Stefani yeah okay I still call her
Gwen there are some great nicknames over
the years aren't they but it's always
um oh no I can't say that that's really
rude but yeah they're the best but the
best ones are the ones that you probably
shouldn't say live you know do you have
do you have Sten you have a company
called Stenner stairlift in America
Harris Stenner airlift Stenner it's the
they do stairlifts for all people but
the company is called Stenner over here
anyway I I shattered my back right so I
couldn't um walk very well at all I've
I've never really recovered I still walk
a bit funny now um I walk a little bit
like a teddy bear I keep getting the
piss at me for it but anyway um so I was
in this Pub and there was the toilets up
some stairs and I was like oh [__] so I
walked up the stairs and I really
struggled and then when I came back down
they start everyone started calling me
Stenner and that's that stuck for about
six months and then went back to Ewok
and wrecked him eventually but um I like
St a stair I I hurt my back this week I
walked out of the house slipped done my
back in so I was off work for a couple
of days my boss the day before I went
back text me and went how's it going
backy
[Laughter]
Chan uh
yeah that's a good one um I don't know
when I broke my foot and I got called
hop along for
ages H come on Hop come on hop along but
that was a bit boring but I called gamy
because I've got my my
leg it's it's apparently a thing that's
common in girls but I had it right so
you know how your legs are normally like
that one of my legs was like that so I W
funny I still walk PNY I was called gamy
for years
because I got a Gam
when I popcorns asked me who I blew my
back out I blew my back out um jumping
out of an airplane and I landed on my
bottom and that's when I that's when I I
hurt my back for the first time I was 19
years
old um from what from what height was it
was it a stationary airplane no it was
it was a I was doing a parachute it was
it wasn't like 3
feet like it was like 20,000 ft or
something
12,000 fet and all you did was blow your
back out you did pretty well yeah yeah
yeah IND funny
walks um no sometimes because you get
these parachutes and you you don't
really have any control over them you
just sort of like go in but sometimes
you get these up gusts you just see I
just basic hit a breeze and it lifted me
up and then as I was about to land so it
lifted me up and then dropped me down so
my legs went up and I literally landed
on my ass um and I I always joke that I
swear to God I I nearly jump back onto
the plane I was like [__]
out um but I didn't know I'd broken it
for years and then I hurt my back again
years later and um I had a an x-ray and
the do and the doctor when did you break
your tailbone because your tailbone just
like that sort of thing um and I'm like
I don't know um and they said you'd know
when you did it you'd know and I was and
then it was I was driving home went
oh that time I jumped out of a plane and
landed
about 15 years
later so i' got got my my my tailbone
looks like the scar on Harry Potter's
head but um it's when you're 18 though
is it man you just like you do [__] like
that and you just run it off and now I
get a what I was in
school I did something to my my tailbone
and my back's never been the same since
like I I I've never been the sporting
type as you probably tell all right I've
never been one to get into sports but I
decided on this one day in school that I
was going to get involved when they
played
football and actually try I thought [__]
it I'm gonna try I'm gonna see if I like
this game spoiler I
[Music]
didn't I
was at the at the top near the goal so I
don't know defense I guess I don't
really know but I was there the ball
come towards me and I decided to do what
I can only describe as an anime
kick which is where I jump up and then
kick the ball like that in the air
that's not what happened what happened
was I
went wrapped on my
ass I did not take part in PE for like
12 months after that oh God and not so
roundhouse it was on like a proper like
JY floor as well you know how hard they
are in schools oh little rubbery too so
you bounce back up and hit it again on
the way back down oh no this this was
like hard wood hard hard wood yeah sport
I play I played rugby for years which
for the American in the room rugby is
like American football um but for people
aren't scared shitless of everything so
there's no pads and you're allowed to
beat the crap out of each other right so
rugby is actually American football done
properly yeah that sounds about right
but for for non- cowards
um but my problem is I loved rugby I I
was I play rugby watch football that's
always my I don't particularly like
playing football but I love I can't be
asked to watch rugby but I love playing
rugby and everything um and I got so so
I played a lot when I was younger um but
I was quick so I could I could run 100
meters in like 12 seconds I was I was I
was rapid um but I'm 5 foot s uh Union
ah um so I'm 5 foot seven so then when I
was 30 I decided I'm G to play rugby
again and this guy that I used to play
with um he's like oh we were man down we
really need you know we need some come
and play so I was like
okay when I was 19
2021 I could outrun the 6 foot three
guys and I was I was really good at the
turn and stuff unfortunately what I'd
realized was I'd slowed down a bit so
all of a sudden the 6' 39 year old guys
not only could catch me they could also
rip me in half so um I played three
games I had three
concussions and um and the manager went
what we're gonna do can you run down the
middle and I'm like no they're gonna
take my head off and he goes yeah we
want we need a penalty can you run down
the middle
like um I got I got I got carried off
three games I got carried off
twice it was not good um
I got I got absolutely
bad um so that was when I realized I'm
getting old that was my
realization then I'm starting to get
old oh well and then on my 30th birthday
I went to the Opticians and they gave me
glasses I'm like this is not a way to
celebrate my 30th
birthday it was it was it was such a
physical transition from 20s to 30s you
know just like I went from 20s I'm young
I can go and get drunk and and I won't
be poly all day tomorrow and probably
the next day and then like literally
next day if if I get drunk now I will be
sick for three days
um nightmare I haven't reached that
point yet I'm 31 I've not I've not
reached the point where I can't drink a
lot yeah I'm usually usually touch wood
fine afterwards and I was I was a master
at it as well boom we'll find out next
Friday I'm going out after work Jim are
you coming next week by the way on
Friday sorry to just start talking
work no I don't work with
you Jim not you Jim
Jim so are you talking to somebody in
the in the
audience Jim are you going next Friday
mate let us know um we need to know um
all right guys look we've been over an
hour I know Harris wants to go get some
dinner oh I'm good I still have an hour
left on these ribs we we can take our
time if need be okay well okay I want to
go get my dinner but I did want to ask
you guys are you watching um
monik yeah I'm one episode behind right
now but yes no watch how you enjoying it
I didn't love the first episode I I
liked everything they did with it I just
think they could have done the entire
episode in about 20 minutes uh I do like
the detail they're doing in the
background of it but it's still not
necessary and Melvin and I were talking
about it with afterthoughts a couple
weeks I guess week two weeks ago
um just as someone who acts and stuff
like the
entire every scene the entire first
episode felt stagnant all the actors are
just sitting in rooms they're not
actually moving there's not like one of
them like oh well let me go grab
something in the kitchen let me fix you
a plate of something you know like they
they do that and then they sit down and
that's kind of the whole episode so I
didn't like that but the second
episode hit it stride a little bit and I
did like the episode Legacy of monsters
yeah
okay Jim told me about this the other
day and have you watched it and I said
no but I think Harris has so J be happy
to know give it a couple of weeks and
then get apple just for a month and and
binge it um I've got Showbox
no watch it then it's it is good um it's
not as good as
maybe the it's very very expensive I
would say it's nearly Cinema quality
it's good oh yeah it's it's well shot
made yeah and Kur Russell's great as
soon as Kur Russell turned up basically
he got there precisely uh Jack O'Neal's
in it yeah Jack o' one
one um well I did just see Godzilla
minus one this past week though and that
was excellent I I was kind of worried in
the first act because you realize very
quickly it's not going to be a story
about Godzilla it's it's a human story
and you know this kind of like the age
old like we don't want a human story in
a Godzilla movie we want a freaking
monster movie this works perfectly uh
the used gu it's not like Jaws where you
don't ever see Godzilla because when you
see Godzilla you see Godzilla but he's
used sparingly which is kind of nice way
should be in a monster movie yeah and
and for that movie to be made for $15
million or $13 million and every episode
of Monarch is $15 million is I might
have that backwards but it's just it's
insane hey over I know it's over $10
million an episode I think there's been
some different numbers thrown out there
um that apple have spent this much apple
spent this much um but um Harris you're
taking the opportunity to kiss ass
apparently I was gonna say sh Laura
don't tell anybody Oh wrong one yeah
yeah hey Jenny styen needs some ribs I'm
gonna make her some ribs just get her
back on the show get her back on the
next video in the next couple of weeks
I'll ask her back on soon um
Jim Jim's asking going where we're going
to the pub
Jim we're all going to the
pub which Pub so then everybody that is
in your region can come meet you yeah be
specific Sid trk Meetup next Friday I
ain't saying witch Pop I don't want Rand
coming to say hello to me I'm very
[Laughter]
awkward I've still never been recognized
in public I still can't believe I've
never been recognized in public I've had
it I've had it once or twice and I don't
I didn't like it yeah we should do a pub
live stream yeah was laughing yeah we
should do that um hopefully next year uh
at least me you me and you Harrison
stormmy will get together fingers
crossed um but yeah Ed uh let fingers
crossed but me and Matt will be together
in May and um we will be may we we will
be is it May May isn't it and then may
together Brad Wright is mine we're
sleeping
together a
yes I'm too I'm too stingy that I didn't
go for two hotel rooms and go one hotel
room so was leing did you at least get
two beds no got a double bed yeah yes I
got a
twin i g say put pill pillow on the
middle or you're going feet to head
either side yeah I'm a lot bigger than J
I will take up most of that
bed no we got a twin room sir um but I
didn't know 100% certain if you were
come in but I wanted to get a room
because there's only like two left so
I've got to book a room so um but I
didn't know if you were coming or not at
that point so uh but anyway um I I'm on
on like Brad wght is mine that boy is
not getting out of that hotel room
without shaking my hand I will hunt him
down um so fingers crossed you think
he'll recognize us like do you think
you'll be like oh look it's then
to Weck
t-shirt um but I am gonna have I am
gonna ask him if we could try to get
together just say her I I don't want I
don't want to drink with him or anything
I just want to shake his hand and and
say her fingers crossed okay anyway but
I'm certainly be busy but and then we
are going to shake hands with Richard
Dean Anderson and Joe Flanigan because
we're paying them to do it so they
haven't got
Choice I've given
you you you've paid for does that mean I
can I'm going with you yeah we can go
together yeah we did a a photo of four
people with Starlight and uh Kimo from
the boys yesterday which was fun cool
yeah you're just paying for app picture
so yeah we can can both go um and thene
ticket yeah get over here sir um you can
set my hand uh I can't in May I will be
on your side of the pawn though but I'll
be in Africa
so that's not our
side that's our side and then a massive
diversion hemispher is you're on this
side of the the pond yeah yeah something
like that it's one of those bonds he's
on a side of the pond like that which
one sectors of the pond that's a pond
there's another
Pond um but that' be cool what are you
going to Africa for
uh my my dad uh won a safari so we're
going Safari and I'm excited how'd you
win a saf
Safari he's he's U like a a a lifetime
member of like a magazine thingy and
they give one person a year a a like a
fancy little thing and he's a lucky man
he's my both my parents win Raffles like
nobody's business if you need somebody
to win Raffles bring them uh my my mom
won a car a bike and a purse in a raffle
in one night before Jesus Christ and my
dad and I won lottery ticket last night
and I don't know if I won got him to get
you that Peter's just come up with
exactly what I was thinking because you
are from Texas don't kill anything I
said Safari it's a picture Safari it
better be no not Lock and Load we're
going on Safari boys different shooting
I got my camera in the other room yeah
when they go oh there's a line over
there shoot they mean a picture
bloody Texans get out where' you get the
gun from I've always got a
gun well I do have that but I'm not
going there with
that he didn't
win a dam I did not win the
lottery so made like last week if you
won the lottery would you keep doing Sid
Trek and I'm don't do it for the
freaking
money i' do it
more legit yeah anyway guys we we'll
call it a lovely evening you Harris go
and um tell us if you get any videos at
La ComiCon let us know that'd be good uh
I got a few I just got to get them sent
to me and I got
you well if you do get them on them
thing and share them on the Community
page and oh before we go actually let's
have one more quick thing I put a a
comment I was doing a video yesterday
Mac um with mac
and it might have been popcorn I'm not I
can't remember who did it now who
suggested it but they said basically put
a um question on the channel when Amazon
do Stargate will Amazon ruin it will
Amazon able to do a good Stargate show
basically just very simple yes and no
right oh I saw that 609 votes yeah 609
votes it's it's a slightly stupid
question I'll I'll give that because I
mean we don't we don't know certain lots
of things but um just from what Amazon
and MGM have been doing in the last
couple of years how confident are you is
really the question what was you how
what would you guys answer first before
we I tell you the
results not that confident honestly
which is not good think about it I'm I'm
I don't know I think they're probably
doing all right job because it's not
Amazon that's going to be making it it's
going to be whoever they hire to make
the thing yeah so as long as they get
the right people to make the thing I'm
I'm fairly confident especially if it's
going to be the people that we've we've
heard about yeah which we hope so
um yeah it's a it's a that's pop exactly
it's it's a it's a public confidence
check which I think is fine somebody did
say question I did have S say no no come
on this is about it's it's your opinion
it's
not I'm not going to tell you you're
wrong it's it's opinion but anyway 50 9%
of 609 votes have said yes um Amazon
will produce good Stargate so there is a
there was a confidence there 41% said no
I didn't I didn't put maybe I thought
that was confusing so um what do you
guys think numers no maybe I don't know
can you repeat the
question leave me alone well stop asking
stupid
questions I'm trying to think of it like
in the sense of what Amazon the the
shows Amazon has on Prime already and
have made and it's not that I don't like
any of them because I do like the vast
majority of them the only ones that I
don't think I've like thoroughly enjoyed
would be like rings of power because I I
part of that's the expectations are so
high though um that's always problem
expect one way or another though it
didn't deliver so I don't I don't I
don't know because their everything they
do tends to be a little more Niche so
it's it's not like it's looking for
larger audiences and Stargate needs if
it's going to be that thing for them
they need a larger audience
obviously it's it's it's up to who's
writing who's hiring honestly
I and they haven't been great at that in
the past either so it doesn't like raise
I I would say that 5140 is 49 was that
no yeah
M there we go um I would say that's
probably my confidence level and not
confidence level right there like
picturized if that makes
sense yeah we'll find out in
2034 I'm only I'm really hoping
something comes out in like like we we
get something in like January February
time if it's going to be a TV series we
should know in January because that's
when MGM put out their development
list so yeah yeah January early February
I've I've decided every time you say by
this date I'm just gonna ignore
it it doesn't Happ always keep my hopes
up if yeah this
has
[Music]
maybe Jes well I've I was doing the Tik
toks and I I I every time had a date
that you said I would go on Tik Tok make
make the prediction or just you know say
say the same thing the last time you did
that was not based on me you went off on
your own with that one I I suggested a
possibility and you basically went it's
happening I went that's not what I said
wait which one uh was it the last one um
on Stargate day when it was the um the
anniversary of the
movie and yeah that from anyone I just
said that might make sense and you went
it's
happening Jesus
bud you ran with that I didn't get any
views though I didn't get any views but
some of them did get views like quite a
lot and then like the day would come and
the next day and so the people comment
back on that video going this didn't
nothing did it and I'm like no it
[__]
didn't I think we realized after oh
God very early on
Amazon's um tenure that we were hearing
rumors and and and they they were just
yeah this isn't but there are reasons
why it hasn't happened I think the only
one we ever had that was firm that we
were actually re really confident on
with San Diego ComiCon and but that's
been um repeated by and that's I think
that's the only time I've
said this is this is really nailed on
this is happening other than that it's
always been uh somebody's opinion is or
you know San Diego ComicCon was the only
time we were really confident and the
strik screwed it so um but that's been
repeated by loads of people since saying
yeah it was they were going to do it at
San Diego ComiCon it was happening they
booked the the people sort of thing it's
gone as far as they were planning it and
then then March early April they decided
to pull out but other than that it's
been
the rumor or opinion or
whatever and yeah and it's not happened
yet and now it's not going to happen I
don't think till next
summer he maybe we'll be there yeah well
unless MGM get the series there begging
for and apparently there's been a verbal
promise they will be getting a series
but we don't we don't know when that
might they might say you can have a
series after the movie you're not having
it till then though so in which case
it'll be
2025 January development list
if we're get a movie
first so we'll see we'll find out wrong
one yeah because they they were gonna do
a movie then follow up with a TV show
originally that was the
plan first yeah then about six months
after that they'll announce the series
um and then yeah so I which in that
which case I think it'll be San Diego
ComicCon next year we get an
announcement um
but yeah with all this Studio nonsense
going
on if it does happen at San Diego Comic
Con next year I'm going back on Tik Tok
I'm stitching my video where I said it's
coming at San Diego ComiCon and I'll go
I was right I was just a year late a
year early sorry got the year wrong man
was so close like this close my crystal
ball wasn't like it wasn't as
clear one number out you can't blame me
for that man oh David just brought up a
really good point in the chat he said
the movie will be out just in time for
the next strike which is in three years
that's about right actually what if what
if they make a movie then immediately
have to pause for another year and then
it screws everything up again no it'll
come out about then if they announce it
next year it'll take two years basically
that will just be another thing that
stops Stargate because everything seems
to stop
Stargate everything well I mean um they
haven't announced
RoboCop um we've got no news on Legally
Blonde 3
the thing we really but MGM haven't
actually announced anything any new big
projects um MGM have announced a couple
of TV until they actually start filming
is when I'll get excited because they've
already announced things in the past and
then nothing's happened with it dude so
girl they can film it and still not get
released ask was going to drop it go do
that Looney Tunes movie until we get the
trailer I going to get excited I I'm
going to be sat in the cinema with the
trailers running thinking this might
still the still might not
happen I'm in the cinema until until the
fil you'll be in the cinema and the
cinema will close it'll lose power or
something we're shutting down all films
areed you can't watch this but all of us
know no just you oh
BL they just won't let me watch it um
probably not if they're not sure it's
going to be very good but yeah the world
it's crazy in
it right I'm going to go eat so thanks
guys been lovely again um let us know
how um get us a picture of you and Chen
Harris well I I will yeah we're uh I'm
wearing Sidetrack stuff today so we're
gonna get some good pictures oh yes
definitely get a couple of pictures and
sir thank you us a nice little video
message yeah
that
I I'll I'll talk to you off screen all
right cool an idea just a thought I'll
message you and ask you all right then
guys have a good one um everybody
will'll see you next week uh next week
we've got a couple of people from the
companion on um I think we're doing a
Saturday with Rebecca and then Sunday
we've got one of The Producers on um
who's the man united fan who nobody will
knows face but I just like the guy he's
funny yeah he's coming on on Sunday oh
nice so
yeah I just I just like him he's a fun
guy so and I've been bugging him for
weeks and he's finally agreed to come on
so um so yeah we're having a bit of a
companion week next week mainly because
they want to advertise what they're
doing for Christmas but we will make
them talk to us as well at the same time
so um but now they're they're amazing
lovely people and they're massive
Stargate fans so it'll be a Stargate esy
weekend next weekend good
people obviously
like oh my God we we need to get Tommy
on in
February on the on the 14th
specifically what's his
surname
Valentine yeah okay and it is
Valentine's Day will you be my Valentine
Tommy
Valentine a video for us right we're out
of here thank you so so much have a
lovely weekend whatever's left and um
yeah say byebye everybody adios
y'all
[Music]
chacho